tenter de trouver une voie médiane voilà
en résumé la position de la france
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
avant le déclenchement de la vase ion
russe emmanuel macron avait tenté déjà
d'obtenir de vladimir poutine le
maintien d'une voie diplomatique
son succès dès le début de la guerre le
président français confirme cette
position soutien à l'ukraine mais aussi
maintien du dialogue avec la russie
c'est pour cela que si j'ai change
constamment avec le président céline ski
j'ai aussi choisi de rester en contact
et resterai en contact
autant que je le peux et autant que
c'est nécessaire avec le président
poutine la france se pose en moteur de
l'unité européenne dans cette crise à la
tête de l'union depuis début janvier
paris pousse pour des sanctions
historique contre moscou à l'image de ce
sommet organisé à versailles en mars où
les membres de l'union s'accordent pour
sortir progressivement de leur
dépendance aux hydrocarbures russes
ainsi que pour un soutien militaire à
l'ukraine emmanuel macron joue alors la
carte de la fermeté sur de nouvelles
sanctions économiques contre la russie
rien n'est interdit rien mes tableaux
nous ferons tout ce que nous considérons
comme étant efficace qu'un était utile
pour stopper la russie
dans ce chemin de l'agression fin avril
la france s'engage un peu plus pour
soutenir militairement l'ukraine environ
100 millions d'euros de matériel avec
l'envoi de canons d'artillerie caesar de
missiles antichars milan ainsi que des
obus solidarité aussi avec kiev lors du
massacre de boue de chat quand emmanuel
macron dénonce les crimes de l'armée
russe position d'équilibriste en
revanche sur une éventuelle adhésion de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne qui elle
veut aller vite mais manuel mâcon
prévient oui cette adhésion se fera mais
ce processus prendra des décennies son
ministre en charge de l'europe enfonce
le clou elle pourrait prendre 15 à 20
ans
des propos qui passe mal à kiev où la
ministre des affaires étrangères en
visite a voulu rassurer
offrir dès maintenant les possibilités
de coopération je dirais même des
garanties de coopération à l'ukraine qui
ne sont en aucun cas un substitut à sa
marche vers l'union européenne cette
posture française a aussi des limites
quitte à froisser l'ukraine dernier
exemple en date avec ses déclarations d'
emmanuel macron il appelle une nouvelle
fois à une solution diplomatique dans le
conflit il ne faut pas humilier la
russie pour que le jour où les combats
cesseront nous puissions bâtir un chemin
de sortie par les voies diplomatiques
réaction immédiate de la diplomatie
ukrainienne pour qui ces déclarations ne
font qu humilier la france symbole aussi
de cette doctrine de la voie médiane
voulue par paris avec un risque se
retrouver isolés voire perdants des deux
côtés